c'est un levier qui est très droit qui
est très sévère avec avec nous et je
pense que nous savons nous allons avec
ce monsieur est peut-être que des fois
ce n'est pas toujours bien marrant mais
les résultats sont là je pense que nous
sommes là pour travailler dans une bonne
ambiance et je pense qui est mêlé fois
peut-être traité qui charme et que s'ils
voulaient l'étaler à l'école stéphanoise
où on a fait beaucoup de travail je
pense que à l'heure actuelle ça paye
et peut-être qu'un jour l'olympique
lyonnais sera prêté comme saint-etienne
est mis les choses au point dès qu'il
est arrivé
tout le monde sait à quoi s'en tenir il
ya une ligne de conduite à sur ceux qui
s'écartent parra sait ce qui l'attend
comme tous les entraîneurs moderne
jacquet fait revoir chaque semaine
métaux scop matches précédents c'est une
méthode qui a fait ses preuves et
jacques et ne manque jamais d'obliger
tous ces joueurs a passé une heure et
demi devant le récepteur placé dans les
vestiaires
[Musique]
les loups on été empruntés
[Applaudissements]
enfin demain à l'égard des deux bien la
version équipe de marseille est
difficile à manoeuvrer vous la
connaissez autrement et on risque
d'avoir quelques problèmes si on joue
aussi lentement s'est vu alors demain à
17 heures 1
aimé jacquet 35 ans est le plus jeune
entraîneur de france après une carrière
de 12 ans à saint-etienne il est devenu
presque naturellement le patron de
l'olympique lyonnais que
j'étais pas destiné à faire entraîneur
je dois avouer que monsieur batta
m'avait un peu poussé je n'irais dans ce
métier et puis les événements ont fait
que je me suis retrouvé propulsé à la
tête de cette équipe lyonnaise
quand on vous voit comme ça on a
l'impression que vous êtes timide et
enfin c'est une fausse timidité car j'ai
pu constater que vous étiez au contraire
très autoritaire bon je ne sais pas si
je suis très autoritaire je pense que je
suis animé d'un sentiment qui est celui
ci sait que j'aime bien le travail bien
fait j'aime le travail honnête avec tout
le respect que l'on doit aux joueurs ou
à tous ceux qui font partie du football
en dehors du football qu'est ce qui vous
intéresse dans la vie mais jacquet vous
avez des mes passions d occupation ont
une passion
je pense que c'est la lecture puis
j'adore les promenades en montagne
ce qui me manque énormément ici à lyon
c'est le moment le plus pénible pour un
entraîneur quand il pénètre livide sur
le terrain juste avant le coup d'envoi
et hier il a eu l'occasion jacques et de
se montrer crispé anxieux même si en fin
de compte c'est un hommage qui nous lui
rendons à lui aussi il a accepté les
décisions de larbitre
oh
je n'ai pas pour habitude de discuter
les décisions dans des cimetières qu'on
va décider que mario était expulsé je
pense qu'en là qu'il a agi très
honnêtement ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'il ya tout le monde s p -a pas je me
fie à sa décision
[Musique]